it's one of the oldest political sayings
if you want a friend in washington get a
dog
joe biden got a dog and the poor mangy
old thing won't stop sinking his teeth
into the ankles of secret service agents
uh the dog that is not uh not joe cesar
milan is known to millions
as the dog whisperer as seen on
television screens in every corner of
this earth
uh but he joins us now on the phone
cesar your
uh view is that uh this is all caused
not by the dog but by
tension in the white house
well you know animals do react uh from
the energy and environment
uh but this is uh a perfect example of
not having a safety protocol to
introduce dogs
into the white house right so it's the
same protocol for any house
it's just accident happens because
there's no safety protocol
so we can't blame the dog that's first
the first thing we have to understand is
we can't blame the dog we have to take
full responsibility of how to introduce
a dog into an environment first and then
introduce
the dog into the new people so he gained
the trust the respect and the love
then you have harmony all right
but you but you have a situation here
where the
the dog is in an environment with with
hundreds of people
uh he i mean in a sense he doesn't have
the life of a real dog he's not being
walked by
uh his owner every every day he's being
walked by
government dog walkers who are secret
service agents doesn't that complicate
the situation
absolutely not that makes him more
social he has more friends
there's a big opportunity here if
everybody understands the same thing
and practice the same behavior
everybody's going to be made your best
friend
so this is the it takes a village to
raise a child so this is where as a
village
if they do the same thing if they have
agreement commitment and follow through
everybody is going to speak dogs so that
way everybody can connect communicate
the reason why i can
help a dog anywhere in the world is
because it's the same language
it's just in the white house or in your
house or in my house
we have to learn to speak dogs in order
for a dog to understand
what we want express respect and love
do you think there's a complicating
factor this is a rescue dog and i've had
rescue dogs and i love
rescue dogs but do you think when you're
bringing a
rescue dog into a government facility
as you said a very tense place one of
the most stressful places
on earth i would imagine do you think a
rescue dog has different challenges
there
no because we all have issues we all
come with issues
you know after 20 years of age people
have issues so a rescue dog means a dog
that had
issues and there was place into a
shelter it doesn't mean he can't go back
to normal
you know so so back to normal means the
human gives exercise mental stimulation
and affection
body my heart that returns him back to
normal
abnormal as people didn't give that you
know so rescue dog doesn't mean they're
broken
rescue dog means they had a human prior
to them
they didn't know how to fulfill the life
of a dog so the dog became unstable
right well well thank you thank you for
explaining so you're fairly optimistic
that if they just
look at it in dog terms as opposed to
people terms
the secret service and all the other
human beings around this dog
can actually get him to be a socialized
member of the white house scene that's
uh that's hardening to know actually
thank you for that
uh say so the dog whisperer joining us
on the phone